the pro-abortion movement sent its best
and brightest to capitol hill yesterday
to defend the practice at its most
imperiled moment and it turns out that
the pro-abortion best and brightest are
not particularly bright
so abortion should be allowed then by
your definition for any reason for any
purpose at any stage right
i trust people to make decisions about
their body and then when relevant i
think that they need to consult their
medical
practitioners okay and not if it is let
me just ask you this question if it is
not lawful and morally acceptable to
take the life of a ten-year-old child i
assume you agree with that right that
would be wrong correct
i believe that okay and a two-year-old
child same thing that would be murder we
would all agree that's wrong then what
is the principal distinction between the
human being that is two years old or
nine months old or one week old or an
hour old than one that is eight inches
further up the birth canal in the uterus
what's the difference why is it okay in
the latter case and not the former cases
i trust people to determine what to do
with their own body wow
full stop
full stop i
uh
uh trust bodies full stop that woman's
name is amy arambidae
she is a professional abortion activist
that woman has a degree in philosophy
from the university of texas
she graduated from law school she has
worked her entire career in the abortion
industry specifically in public affairs
defending abortion
and when she is confronted with even the
most basic objection to abortion
the best defense she can muster is
i trust people to use their bodies beep
boop beep boop
so
embarrassing and it's not even her fault
it's not even her fault this chickie is
probably among the best and brightest in
the abortion industry the problem is not
her lack of polish the problem is that
she is being asked to defend the
indefensible i'm michael knowles it's
the michael knoll show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from tragic mobile
mind games who is quoting joe biden
apparently here saying my family's very
religious i'm a devout catholic and my
son is a crystal methodist that's not
nice that is not nice that's very funny
but that is not nice
okay his sons had a lot of problems drug
problems lady problems
hard drive pro technology problems when
you want to invest in some technology i
would strongly recommend you check out
alto ira right now go to altoira.com
michael you know when there are
fluctuations in the market when things
go down a little bit that can frequently
be the time to buy they call it buying
the dip do you own any bitcoin ethereum
cardano or other cryptocurrency well
with an alto crypto ira you can trade
crypto like bitcoin and avoid or defer
the taxes this is the key a lot of
people are interested in getting enter
into crypto and to start investing in
crypto but don't do it in a way where
you're going to get punished on the tax
end do it in a tax advantaged retirement
account altos crypto ira is the easy way
to get crypto into an ira you trade all
you want without that tax headache you
create an account in as little as a few
minutes you can start with as little as
10 bucks and there's no setup charges
you get secure trading 24 7 through
alto's integration with coinbase they've
got industry leading security the
advanced encryption standard for wallets
and private keys multiple ways to fund
your account cash contribution a
rollover 401k pretty much anything you
want open an alto crypto ira account
with as little as 10 bucks today alto
ira dot com slash michael that's a l t o
i r a dot com m i c h a e l start
investing in crypto today alto ira.com
michael
this was so
hilariously pathetic yesterday on
capitol hill
it was sad
that there are people who have devoted
their entire lives to defending
infanticide that that is sad but it was
really funny that at the at the moment
where it all matters at the moment where
roe v wade could be overruled the
abortion industry they've got to get it
all together and take their absolute
best shot to defend abortion they've got
absolutely nothing it wasn't just that
lady amy a rambi day there's another
woman an actual abortionist her name is
yeshika robinson she was asked also by
this hero congressman mike johnson did
an absolutely incredible job
really really excellent stuff grilling
these people she was asked
when does a baby become human here's her
answer
you're not going to answer this question
but how about this one how does one
qualify as fully human
what makes a human being
what makes a person a human being is
them being born number one that's why we
have birthdays
what makes a human this is the this is
the highest level of philosophical
sophistication from the abortion
movement
what makes a human being a human
is when they're born that's why we have
birthdays
that's why we have birthday is it now i
thought we had birthdays to commemorate
the day when you were born to
commemorate your birth
birthdays are not called becoming human
days
that the two have nothing to do with one
another and by the way birthdays can be
fungible
people can induce labor sometimes people
go into labor a little bit earlier they
can delay when they give birth to some
degree maybe you were supposed to be
born on the 15th but they actually
induce your delivery on the 13th
or maybe it takes a little bit longer
and it's on the 16th
you're telling me that the ontological
change when you become human
is determined by when you pass through
eight inches of of a lady's body or not
even what what if what if you're not
born naturally what if you what if
you're
born through
or what if you're delivered through a
cesarean section does that change things
do you do does the magical thing that
happens when you are pushed out of the
woman
when you're pushed out of your mother
does that does that magical thing happen
when you're cut out of the woman's
abdomen by a doctor
of course not this is insane thinking
when do you become i made this point on
the show the other day but i think it's
important to reiterate
very often the pro-abortion movement
will try to say well look we don't
obviously when a baby is born that's a
human being entitled to all the rights
of human beings
but when a baby is still in the womb
they don't have all those rights for
some reasons and they'll try to come to
some
arbitrary line at which you become a
human well when you've got all your
fingers when you've got all your toes
when you develop your eyeballs when your
heart is more recognizably beating
that's when you become a human
that doesn't make very much sense to me
one because some people are born without
their fingers some people are born
without their toes some people are born
without those distinguishing features
some people lose it along the way in
their lives if they have an injury are
you telling me they lose their humanity
there no of course not the difference
between having partially formed fingers
and fully formed fingers
is is a much more trivial distinction
than the difference between
being alive and not being alive we know
even the abortion movement will admit
when a baby is conceived
that baby is alive has all the
characteristics of life
and that baby is a human a distinct
human not a dog not a cat not a giraffe
a human being not a tadpole even if it
looks a little bit like a tadpole it's a
human being
don't you think that the distinction
between
human and not human the distinction
between alive and not alive is more
significant than the distinction between
his fingers are a little bit bigger now
and not don't you think it's more
important than the distinction she's
making between
your eight inches up the birth canal to
your eight inches out of the birth canal
no which she's she is just completely
avoiding the question and she what she
is really saying is i'm not going to
answer
your question about the baby i'm not
going to answer your question about
human life i'm just going to make the
claim that it is fine to kill a baby
when he's eight inches up the birth
canal compared to when he's further down
the birth canal
doesn't really work this is why the
pro-abortion movement now is doing
everything they can to avoid talking
about abortion itself that's why they're
saying that the dobbs case which could
overrule roe v wade it's not really
about abortion it's about contraception
it's about
uh
the obergefell redefinition of marriage
it's about interracial marriage oh yes
if you if we get rid of roe vs wade
they're coming for your interracial
marriage what are you talking about
find find me one conservative in the
country who has said that
you can't they're all they're trying to
do is distract and now what they've
settled on especially in in the light of
the buffalo shooting now that they're
exploiting a mass killing up in buffalo
a few days ago they're saying that
really the pro-life movement it's all
about white supremacy this might be the
most ridiculous argument of all
it's hard i mean it's hard to pick it's
hard to pick which is more poisonous
cyanide or arsenic you know which is
more ridiculous the arguments about life
are the arguments about white supremacy
but this is what they're saying there is
a prominent twitter account uh goes by
el norte rieda
uh i don't know what her real name is
she has a phd
she's a published author she's got a big
old platform she's got a blue check mark
and yesterday she posted onto social
media she said the majority of people
who get abortions are white
overturning roe v wade neutralizes two
major threats to capitalist white
supremacy the declining birth rate and
the shrinking white minority criminalize
abortion ensure a future majority white
working class
okay
she posted
a little infographic here to back up her
claims
the infographic
disproves her claims she says the
majority of abortions are are of white
people the the infographic she posts
says race of abortions 39 white so right
off the top this woman doesn't even know
what a majority is majority is 50 plus
one
the a plurality of abortions are of
white people fair enough and she says so
if we get rid of abortion you're
disproportionately going to have more
white people in the population so let's
look at let's just look at those
statistics she says
according to her graph
39 of abortion patients are white
28 black 25 hispanic six percent asian
pacific islander three percent other
okay so the plurality of abortion
patients are white
39
but 62 of the country is white
28 of abortion patients are black
only about 13 of the country is black 25
of hispanic patients of of abortion
patients are hispanic something like 18
of the country is hispanic
meaning
abortion
disproportionately kills hispanic and
especially black babies
white babies are relatively
underrepresented in abortion if you
overrule roe v wade and then if you go
further to criminalize abortion the
effect will not be
disproportionately more white babies it
will be disproportionately more hispanic
and especially disproportionately more
black babies the infographic she's
posting the statistics that the
pro-abortion movement is using
proves the opposite of the point that
she thinks she's making this is the best
and brightest they've got folks if you
were on the fence about abortion
i think you can fall off the fence now i
think it's pretty clear which side has
all of the arguments and all of the
truth and it's all coming to light
and it makes me feel really good almost
as good as my ex chair right now go to
xchairnulls.com and then you can just
feel as good as i do all right because
most of us i think most of us probably
spend more time every day in our office
chair than we do in our cars or we do in
our beds which is why it's so important
to invest in the right chair to spend
those hours with the right level of
support
and comfort to get the most productivity
out of your day you're gonna be spending
a lot of time in it make the investment
make sure that you're feeling good
you're not screwing up your spine and
your bones and your old skeleton x-chair
has made our time at the office here so
much better my only complaint about
xchair is that the moment it was
delivered at the office all these
jackals at the daily wire tried to steal
my x-chair don't let that happen to you
exterior has got all the top technology
patented dynamic variable lumbar dvl
offers the ultimate customized support
and the x chair can give you a massage
it can heat you up or cool you down it
does everything okay thanks to their new
armrests you are going to be feeling
like you are in the perfect position all
day long go to externals dot com
that is the letter x chair knowles
kennedywles.com or call one eight four
four four x chair that's number four x
chair for one hundred dollars off your
order extra has a 30 day guarantee of
complete comfort you can finance your
purchase for as little as 30 bucks a
month x chair knowles.com
what this is coming down to
especially in the light of the
the midterm elections especially in the
light of the democrats looking for
anything to try to gin up their base
they're losing on the economy they're
losing on immigration they're losing on
foreign policy they're losing on
inflation gas food
go down the list the democrats are
underwater so now they are going back to
their most basic strategy they're trying
to gin up racial resentment
and this has worked for them for a long
time and they're tying it into this
abortion issue there's a woman
uh joe louiseman
never never heard of her before but
she's apparently got a podcast and a
fairly big platform
yesterday she said quote
i would rather get an abortion than have
a brown child who ends up being adopted
by white evangelicals
it is not a kindness to children of the
global majority
global what does that mean she just
means not white people
she said another obviously
that includes
black people hispanic people asian
people all sorts of people
and even within that to say asian right
you're talking about what a quarter of
the world's population or more but so
we're talking about what
japanese chinese indian does that all of
these people they're just she's just
saying when she says global majority she
just means everyone but white people
just don't like it is not a kindness to
children of the global majority
to give them to people who will
traumatize them with self and ancestral
hatred
and abortion is an act of love
imagine hating white people so much
so much
that you want to kill your children just
despite white people
that's what we're talking about here
obviously it goes without saying
if you said this about any other race
you would not only be deplatformed you
would be socially ostracized if your
employer found out you would lose your
job if your school found out you would
be expelled
you might be prosecuted
we still have pretty strong speech
protections in this country they might
find a way to prosecute you
if you said i would rather my child die
than be raised by a black person
or bring in the the
religious aspect here i'd rather my
child die than be raised by a muslim or
something you you would be
totally booted out of society and yet we
are told that it is white people and
christian people who have all of the
privilege
of course that's not the case the only
the only groups that you're allowed to
discriminate against legally
are
white people in race
men
in sex
and
straight people i guess if you talk
about sexual desire
and
christianity
bears a fair brunt of it in the public
square it's the it's totally the
opposite of what people are saying and
i suspect they actually don't see it
i suspect that their hatred has just
driven them crazy anger and hatred and
wrath can drive you crazy
obviously crazy this woman is saying i'd
rather kill my kids than have my kids
raised in a loving home
by this race that i hate
white people by this religious group
that i hate christians
is it any wonder right now that the
department of homeland security is
preparing for violence in the wake of
the supreme court decision that's what
we have this now from axios has just
gotten a memo from the department of
homeland security they're preparing for
violence following the abortion ruling
yeah
you don't say
you don't you don't say you're the group
that the left came out there was uh one
leftist group in particular ruth sent us
that said that angry mobs need to go to
the justices homes and force them to
change their minds and use a diversity
of tactics peaceful protest is one
tactic but we need a diversity of
tactics and then the mobs do go to the
homes and scream and yell outside of the
homes where the justice's little
children sleep and sam alito's got to go
into hiding with his family to an
undisclosed location and now the dhs
says you know we might get some violence
when this decision comes out
oh and by the way the white house won't
condemn the angry mobs outside the
justices homes the white house says we
don't have an official position on where
people protest
and actually at one point the
president's spokesman jen saki came out
and said well i actually
sort of encourage people to to be
outside of the homes
it was unclear exactly her wording was
enough that it gave her some wiggle room
as to what exactly she was saying but
that that's what she seemed to imply
oh yeah we might have some violence
after the decision you don't say and so
here's the big picture according to
axios
law enforcement agencies are
investigating social media threats to
burn down or storm the supreme court
building and murder justices and their
clerks
as well as attacks targeting places of
worship
and abortion clinics and abortion
clinics
what hold on you're so the the ruling
that comes out
is that
we're not going to have as much abortion
in the country
and all of the threats that we've seen
have been against the pro-lifers by the
pro-abortion people and then in this
news report from axios they're saying
and they're worried about
they're worried about threats against
abortion clinics too why why would there
be threats against abortion clinics
they go on
they say here's the context the context
around this memo abortion related
violence historically has been driven by
anti-abortion extremists
okay gotta pause it right there
statistically 100 percent of
abortion-related violence has been
committed by abortionists because
abortion kills little babies
and since roe versus weight it's killed
about 62 million babies nationwide
and it is true there have been a handful
of attacks by pro-life advocates on
abortion clinics and against
abortionists there have been a very
small number of those
and you know that's bad
we don't we don't want vigilante
violence in america
i don't know i'm going to pick a number
at random this will not be the precise
number let's say it's been a dozen
attacks let's say let's say it's more
let's say it's been 100 attacks which it
hasn't been
62 million
murders of babies
a handful of attacks on abortion clinics
that does not mean that historically the
majority of abortion-related violence
has been from the pro-lifers
statistically zero percent of
abortion-related violence has been from
pro-lifers and right now all of the
violence is coming from the pro-abortion
side they're outside the justices homes
well no it's kind of both sides and it's
really more those pro-lifers
some racially or ethnically motivated
violent extremists embrace of pro-life
narratives may be linked to the
perception of wanting to save white
children or fight white genocide the
memo says also again so
it's not just some kooky lady on twitter
who's trying to tie the pro-life
movement into white supremacists or
something it's the department of
homeland security and it's axios it's a
major establishment media platform but
as we've shown you the statistics show
the opposite if if a white supremacist
wanted to
grow the white percentage of the
population and deplete the black and
other minority percentage of the
population that white supremacist would
be on the pro-abortion side because
abortion does that not pro-life the
effect of overruling row and having
having protections for life in america
will be the growing of black and brown
communities
and
proportionally the shrinking of white
communities it's totally the opposite
these guys are so dishonest but they're
so desperate to defend infanticide that
they will grab at anything they can and
they know that the worst thing you can
be called in modern america is a racist
that's just the way our culture works
now it's the it's the most evil horrible
worst thing you can possibly be called
is a racist and so they're trying to do
that in official government documents
and now they're saying okay
this time maybe some extremist acts
could come from abortion rights
proponents as well there's no right to
an abortion there's no this is the last
desperate gasp of the children of moloch
trying to defend their ridiculous
hideous heinous sacrifice and they send
their best people their top smartest
most genius powerful people to go defend
it and it falls flat because there's no
defense of it whatsoever
none whatsoever do you want to talk
about exploiting a tragedy joe biden
flew to buffalo
he gave
one of the worst presidential speeches
i've ever seen
the saving grace of it is that joe biden
is extremely old and feeble and so he
couldn't speak for very long i think the
whole thing was about 15 minutes
he went to
to ostensibly to comfort the victims of
buffalo but that's not really why he
went he didn't go to comfort the victims
of a terror attack he doesn't care about
them he doesn't care about the terror
attack
he if he cared about that he would have
gone to waukesha
when a guy drove his four political
purposes drove his car into a crowd of
when a black racist drove his car into a
crowd of white people at an early
christmas parade for political reasons
with all sorts of manifestos and
political statements that he'd posted
online but
joe biden didn't want to talk about that
because that undercut his political
narrative and he said we don't have
enough presidential assets to to go and
visit but then the minute that the
buffalo shooting happens they look to
check all of the boxes to defend their
political narrative and so he flies up
their asap and the point of his speech
was not to comfort anybody it was not to
bring america together
it was not to have a kumbaya moment
the point of the speech was to smear
conservatives as white supremacists to
implicitly attack republican politicians
to attack republican talk show hosts
they've now focused a lot of their
efforts on going after tucker carlson
really they're talking about all of us
though
and to say that if you in any way
do not go along with the left-wing
orthodoxy that you are responsible for a
massacre that happened up in
up in buffalo he was calling to censor
the internet up there to censor
conservatives on the internet and
comparing it to half of the country that
voted for donald trump now before we get
to those
clips i've got to
tell you about something i'm so excited
about on the show that is that i will
finally get to hear from you not just
with your writing but in your own voice
that is because of pure talk
pure talk is giving us the voice mail
bag
we will be hearing the voicemail bag
tomorrow we debuted it last week how do
you do it you go you record your
voicemail on your phone then you or your
computer or wherever then you go to the
daily wire website you click on the
shows you click on the michael knowles
show click on the mailbag and then in
that little email section for the
mailbag you just drop in your mp3 file
your little audio file
and then we'll play it on the show and
it's going to be wonderful i'll hear
from you tomorrow
also you know jonathan isaac was the
only nba player who stood for the
national anthem when every other player
was kneeling down during the lead-wide
demonstrations in support of blm
he's hosting a live book signing for his
book why i stand at 7 p.m eastern on
premiere collectibles youtube channel
if you want to get your signed copy and
a chance to ask jonathan a question go
to premierecollectables.com isaac then
at 8 pm eastern uh ben's third thursday
book club will be uh premiering again uh
he's reading moby dick by herman
melville third thursday book club is not
like any other club you have ever seen
check out the trailer
i want to tell you about my third
thursday book club this is not your
average book club these are the greatest
books in the history of western
literature
we're going to dive into the greatest
works of all time these are the books
that helped form the key pillars of
western civilization and helped define
america and we're going to do it live
with thousands of you our daily wire
members
i'm going to be your personal guide i've
read every one of these books i'm going
to draw out the important lessons and
themes from every book plus i'm going to
be answering your questions along the
way so we actually do read the book
together
you join the book club you are going to
get smarter you're going to get more
knowledgeable because this is an
investment in your most valuable asset
your mind the third thursday book club
it's gonna change the way you think
go to dailywire.com subscribe where new
members can use code shapiro for 20 off
then tune in tonight 8 pm eastern for
ben's third thursday book club we'll be
right back with a lot more
joe biden flies up to buffalo
instead of bringing the country together
he tries to rip the country apart his
first suggestion on how to move forward
together well we need to censor
conservatives on the internet
you can't prevent people from being
radicalized to violence
but we can't address the relentless
exploitation of the internet to recruit
and mobilize terrorism
we just need to have the courage to do
that to stand up
what does joe biden mean by this we can
prevent the exploitation of the internet
to recruit and mobilize violent
terrorism what is he talking about
is he talking about using the government
to prosecute direct threats online
no we already have laws against that we
already do that
is he talking about
uh going in and using the internet to
track al qaeda
uh no we already do that he's talking
about something that he has been pushing
for a long time namely
more censorship on the internet joe
biden when he says terrorists he's not
just talking about mass shooters when he
says terrorists he's not talking about
al qaeda when he says terrorists he's
talking about you
he says at least when he talks about
racists and white supremacists and white
nationalists he's not talking about some
fringe group he's not talking about the
ku klux klan he's not talking about
killers he's talking about you
he has said remember during that
presidential debate he said
trump you're a racist you're a racist
he's insinuating that half of the
country that voted for donald trump at
least half of the country perhaps that
voted for donald trump they're they're
the same as the shooter in buffalo
that's what you if you if you don't
support me it's even worse than when
during the campaign biden said if you
don't support me you ain't black
what you're saying is if you don't
support me you're the guy in buffalo if
you don't support me you shut up a
supermarket you don't support me you're
a terrorist we can you we can go in
and stop people from exploiting the
internet by sharing their views we know
that biden's doing this that's why he
set up the disinformation governance
board there's actually news on that
which we'll get to in just a second
this is why he's adding new layers of
censorship or trying to every day to
shut you
up how do i know what's my proof of this
am i reading too deeply into it no he
makes an a direct comparison between the
shooter in buffalo and
the people who protested at the capitol
on january 6th
these actions
we've seen
in these hate-filled attacks
represent the views of a hate-filled
minority
we can't allow them to distort america
the real america
we can't allow them to destroy the soul
of the nation
as president united states i travel the
world
all the time
and other nations ask me heads of state
in other countries
ask me
what's going on
what in god's name happened on january 6
what happened in buffalo what happened
to ask
excuse me
what happened you know
it's like what happened uh in buffalo
what happened in the oklahoma city
bombing what happened at pearl harbor
what happened when the horn hat guy
danced around the capital rotunda what
happened
at uh nagasaki hold on what did you say
no i said what happened at
pearl harbor no no after that oh i said
what happened at naga no are you you're
comparing
some midwestern dads cracking a coors
light in the capital rotunda to a mass
shooting that left 10 people dead
do you have no shame at all no he
doesn't joe biden doesn't have any shame
he's never had an ounce of shame the guy
lies like he breathes the guy is so
dishonest that has been his defining
characteristic in public life since at
least the 1988 presidential election
when he had to drop out for lying and
for plagiarism and for making up his
academic record
the guy lies like he breeds he is so
shameless
then he runs for president in 2008 he
loses he becomes the vice president 2012
what's he say says mitt romney wants to
put all you black people back in chains
he does it effortlessly he lies
and now he comes up he says oh yeah man
i'm meeting the world leaders and
they're always just like man what's
going on with all your mass shootings
that leave so many people dead and and
and with the horn hat guy
they're no they're not asking you that
they're not
you were just a cynical old political
hack
who is
dancing on the graves of the dead people
in buffalo to score a cheap political
point at donald trump
and his supporters
so so disgusting but at least he's at
least he's laying out his agenda for you
he's saying it directly right he's
saying
if you
protested the 2020 election
didn't kill anybody
didn't attack anybody you just kind of
showed up to the capitol and made a mess
of things
you are a mass killer and we're coming
for you and we're coming for you and
they are they've arrested so many of
those people put them in solitary
confinement when people throw molotov
cocktails
at buildings for eight months with blm
they get off the hook then the vice
president raises money to bail them out
of jail
but if you show up and crack a coors
light at the capitol when the police let
you in in some cases
then you're a violent terrorist you have
to be put in solitary confinement
and anyone who who says otherwise you
need to be kicked off of the internet
it's not just biden
it's not even just cnn and nbc the
former fox news chief political
correspondent carl cameron
has since left fox news now he's showing
up on the liberal news channels
he showed up yesterday on msnbc
to call
for the jailing of conservatives who
spread what he terms misinformation
it really is kind of horrible to think
that uh journalists with national and
international capacity
are putting together this type of
nonsense i think the president did a
great job i wish he had done a lot of
this a lot sooner and we need a lot more
from uh
the left and the middle and uh we got to
watch out because the republicans have
become the purveyors of misinformation
and when our two-party system is broken
like that
democracy is seriously in trouble the
president acknowledged that it's time to
actually start doing things and maybe
taking some names and putting people in
jail
and maybe taking some names and maybe
putting people in jail first to his
claim that the republicans had become
the party of misinformation
this is a man at a moment where the
democrats are claiming that babies are
not babies and boys are actually girls
and donald trump colluded with the
russians
and
on and on oh and the kovit had nothing
to do with the chinese laboratories and
the vaccines are totally safe and
effective and will prevent you from
contracting the virus or transmitting
the virus and that we're only going to
shut down for two weeks to slow the
spread and on and on and on we could be
here all day
when the democrats have spread lie after
lie after lie after lie
he says it's the republicans who are
spreading misinformation because of what
because of what
i don't even know what he's referring to
here
nate tell me the misinformation what is
it can you think of it let me know in
the comments section i'm not i'm not
defending the republican party i'm not
saying it's totally pristine but is
there some major claim that the
republicans have made in recent years
that is obvious misinformation i can't
think of one i can think of a dozen
claims that the democrats are making off
the top of my head
that are obviously false
i can't think of one i'm not even
talking about well i prefer this policy
you prefer that policy i'm just
substantive factual claims i can't think
of one
and he says not only are the republicans
making it we need to put the republicans
in jail who do
remember do you remember when donald
trump would make fun of journalists what
we heard was this is an assault on free
speech and freedom of the press this man
he's a dictator he's a totalitarian now
you've got carl cameron former fox news
chief political correspondent now on nbc
actually calling for jailing journalists
if they're on the right
because i guarantee you he would say
that
most of what i i say on this show
constitutes misinformation
i imagine right
joe biden would say that most of what i
say on the show constitutes
misinformation because i'm giving you
information and according to joe biden
true information is misinformation and
up and down his war and peace and and
freedom of slavery so they would call
this misinformation and they would try
to jail me and they would try to jail
people on writing for conservative
outlets and jail people at conservative
television news stations
they are
they always do what they say that we are
doing they are always projecting and i
shouldn't be surprised by it anymore
because they've been doing it for so
long but their accusations are always
confessions that's just how it goes
we've got some good news on this front
thankfully the ministry of truth the
disinformation government board that joe
biden set up to punish domestic
political
opponents
it's not to punish foreigners like he
pretended it was we already have an
office at the state department focused
on foreign affairs that does that he joe
biden was setting one up at the
department of homeland security to
punish domestic political opponents of
his
well now that's been put on pause
it has been put on pause three weeks
after its announcement largely because
we in the conservative media wouldn't
shut up about it and so the public did
become aware of it and they got a lot of
bad press at the white house for this so
the disinformation government's board is
being paused
intra departmental dhs working groups
focused on disinformation have been
suspended and the chickie who was going
to lead the disinformation group nina
jankowitz has resigned one of the
ironies of this gal running the
disinformation group is that she peddled
disinformation about russia about
russian collusion she peddled
disinformation about some of the biggest
issues that we've talked about for the
last five years and yet she was supposed
to be in charge of disinformation so uh
she resigned and this poor beleaguered
underprepared
under-skilled white house press
secretary karine jean-pierre was asked
about it by peter ducey and she said
well the reason you see why the board
had to be paused for right now
is because of disinformation
so if it's pausing because you think the
board was mischaracterized then the
disinformation board is being shut down
because of disinformation is that what's
happening here look i mean the the board
was put forth for a purpose right to
make sure that we really did a uh really
did address what was happening across
the country when it came to
disinformation
it's going to pause there's been a
mischaracterizations from outside uh
outside forces and so now where we're
going to do is going to we're going to
pause it and we're going to do an
assessment but the work does the work
doesn't stop we're still going to
continue the work the dhs is still going
to continue to work
there is the money line i think
conservatives are celebrating a little
too soon here it's not that the board is
totally going away they might get rid of
this chick nina jankowicz because she
was just such a lightning rod but
they'll just replace her with some more
faceless bureaucrat she says it's a
pause
the work will go on what's the work the
work is censoring you the work is
looking at you the work is trying to
shut you up in the public square i just
love the way peter ducey frames this
question can we let's go back and play
it again because there when he says it
when he drops the line you can see the
reporter sitting next to him i think he
works for uh cbs
i forget his name some people say that
he and i resemble one another he almost
bursts out laughing take a listen so if
it's pausing because you think the board
was mischaracterized then the
disinformation before
being shut down because of the
disinformation is that and there it is
look he's just trying to like bite his
tongue he says that's peter that's a
very good line
so the reason that the board had to be
shut down is because of disinformation
if the disinformation board can't
counter disinformation about the
disinformation board does it sound like
the disinformation board is doing a damn
thing huh
is it about disinformation it is doing a
lot or it could do a lot to censor
conservatives which is what it was about
all the time
speaking of disinformation on the
internet there's a report out now this
is an audit of joe biden's official
potus twitter account
that found
that a much higher percentage of his
followers are fake than previously was
assumed when elon musk went in to buy
twitter
twitter said that five percent or fewer
of the accounts on twitter are fake
and so elon said okay well i'll offer 44
billion dollars or thereabouts to buy
twitter and then elon
pulls a fast one he says wait a second
can you prove to me that fewer than five
percent of the accounts are fake
and the ceo of twitter paraguay rules
says uh well uh no i wish i could but i
can't i'm not able to show my work and
elon says bs that's not true i bet the
number's much higher
and so some
analyses have shown that it's about 20
you look at the potus account it's 50
almost
this is according to uh newsweek and to
conduct the audit newsweek used a
follower audit tool called fake
followers which was created by the data
analytics firm sparktoro and it just
looks at lots of different
characteristics of accounts
and not not one of these characteristics
is firm proof that an account is fake
but when you add them all together
you get an overwhelming likelihood that
an account is fake
this is well one it
just drives home this point that we've
heard about joe biden from the beginning
the most the most
popular president in the history of the
world he got 70 bazillion votes and i
don't know i'm kind of curious about a
little skeptical of some of those
alleged supporters of joe biden but
but second of all this constitutes a
massive fraud
by twitter on the investors
twitter investors are putting their
money into twitter because they believe
that the platform has a certain number
of people on it has a certain amount of
use that advertisers could reach a
certain number of people if it turns out
that it's not five percent of the users
who are fake but it's
20 or more
50 could it be 50 i don't know looks
like it is on biden's twitter account
that's a massive fraud
and it
at a political level it reminds you how
absolutely manipulated our public square
has become which means that's how
absolutely manipulated by a handful of
oligarchs our
whole political order has become because
in a self-government the way you govern
yourself is by speaking and
communicating with one another
but number two it shows you that the
company is just totally rotten so elon
musk could end up buying twitter and
freeing up a little bit of space for
conservatives to speak that would be
nice or he could just burn the whole
thing to the ground
because the whole thing might be built
on sand the whole thing might be a major
fraud
the people who are accusing us
us crazy conspiracy theorists who think
that babies are babies and boys aren't
girls us crazy wacko fringe extremist
misinformers those people who are
accusing us of misinformation are
themselves guilty of perpetrating and
spreading and propagating the most
misinformation in our country
sheila jackson lay democrat congressman
she has kovit
hope she gets well soon
i trust that she will
sheila jackson lee is not an anti-vaxxer
she is not one of the people who
disregarded the public health geniuses
she actually followed them and she got
four covid shots
i'm sorry i don't mean to laugh i
shouldn't laugh
sheila jackson lee got four kovid shots
and then got coveted
it's not i shouldn't laugh because i
would expect nothing less she she tweets
out this statement
congresswoman sheila jackson lee tested
positive for covet she is fully
vaccinated and has received her boosters
she encourages everyone to get tested
and fully vaccinated
along with her booster shots she looks
forward to a full and complete recovery
in other words let me translate that
because i know that sounds a little
confusing it is a little confusing the
way she said it she said this is the
statement
politician does a thing that does not
work
she encourages all of you to do that
same thing
and then
and you know what they'll do here come
the misinformer fact checkers are going
to try to shut down this show now
they're going to say no michael though
the vaccines did work because it would
have been so much worse if
she hadn't had them oh yeah
prove it to me well they can't they
can't prove it of course
maybe if she'd gotten the fifth shot
then maybe she wouldn't have gotten
coveted but that's even beside the point
i'm not even making an argument about
whether or not the vaccines reduce your
risk of hospitalization or whatever
we were told
that the vaccines would prevent you from
contracting the virus and spreading the
virus
that's what we were told we were first
of all we were told that the vaccines
worked and were very effective now
people are on their fourth and fifth
shot so i'm a little curious about the
efficacy
and actually they've suspended some of
the vaccines at different times and are
phasing out the johnson and johnson
because it's not exactly safe but okay
never mind putting that to the side for
a second here
we were told by biden and wallensky and
fauci that the vaccine would do what
vaccines are supposed to do
namely prevent you from
contracting the virus and spreading the
virus they said that
explicitly
and then the vaccines didn't do that
so sure maybe the vaccines do all sorts
of other great stuff maybe or maybe not
but they failed to do they don't work at
doing the thing that all the people who
sold us the vaccines told us they would
do
and you still have these misinformers
like well like all of those people biden
and wolenski and fauci and sheila
jackson lee and the entire media
establishment telling you no you've got
get number five
get number six we never said that that
thing that you have us on video saying
we never said that these are not the
droids you're looking for thank goodness
that we have
misinformation specialists thank
goodness we have experts don't you think
barry mccaffrey is retired four star
general
uh barry mccaffrey uh has been giving
his commentary on the war in ukraine
barry mccaffrey just tweeted out a video
ostensibly of the war in ukraine
it says russian aircraft getting nailed
by ukraine missile defense russians are
losing large numbers of attack aircraft
ukraine air defense is becoming
formidable
the video that he posted there i don't
know what i don't know very much but it
didn't didn't look totally real to me
but i'm no expert
i don't what do i know about air defense
systems
it's from a video game
the the retired four-star general expert
posted a clip from a video game
and gave his commentary on how the video
game was proof that ukraine is going to
defeat russia in the war
these are the experts
these are the ex i don't
i don't want to sound anti-intellectual
i don't think that i am
anti-intellectual i don't i don't even
want to sound
anti-education or anti-scholarship or
anti
our experts are complete idiots the
problem is with the experts themselves
the people who go to capitol hill
the people who go to capitol hill and
say we're the expert geniuses on
abortion
they can barely form an english sentence
okay these people
they're not
they're not i was gonna say they're not
sending their best they are sending
their best and their best are
incompetent dr fauci he's probably the
best that the public health
establishment's gonna send you and he's
a liar and an incompetent
and a fraud
and a deceiver and he's been deceiving
us for years that's why we don't trust
them
it's not our problem that we don't trust
these people
it's their problem they're the ones who
have squandered the credibility
that's why we don't trust them if we had
experts elites rulers who were
public-minded and serious and
well-educated and when i say
well-educated i don't just mean book
smarts i mean in their behavior in their
comportment in their in their whole
person if they were dignified and
virtuous
i'd be all for following them i'd be all
for listening to their advice but
they're not they're really really
decayed
it we ain't talking about george
washington here folks we're talking
about crooks and cheaters and idiots who
are running our country
that's why we don't trust them and
they're going to blame us for that
and they're going to call us all sorts
of names deplorable and irredeemable and
stupid and racist and thisist and
thattist and phobic
and they are doing that to deflect away
from their own failures
and their own
shallowness and the traits about
themselves that are in fact the reason
why we don't trust them before we go
speaking of war i
do have to get to one clip
it's really sad but i
you kind of almost have some affection
for the guy
george w bush made the gaffe of all
gaffes speaking about the war well
trying to speak about the war in ukraine
yesterday he had a little bit of a slip
up
in contrast
russian elections are rigged
political opponents
are imprisoned or otherwise eliminated
from participating in the electoral
process
the result is an absence of checks and
balances in russia
and the decision of one man
to launch a wholly unjustified
and brutal invasion of iraq i mean over
ukraine
all right anyway
75. uh
you can't help but have a kind of
affection because there was one man who
launched a brutal unjustified invasion
of iraq uh i mean ukraine
iraq ii
oh my gosh the reason uh the reason i
mentioned this is not to beat up on
george bush as i told you i still have
some some affection for him
it is
because this really complicates
nato's argument right now the the
essential dispute between america
between the west and russia but really
just america's leading the west and
russia in the war in ukraine is over
nato russia says we don't want nato to
move eastward
america says we need nato to move
eastward because you want to move
westward and reconstitute the soviet
union and part of america's argument is
that nato is a purely defensive alliance
but that's not true
nato
was involved in iraq nato was involved
in the invasion of libya
that doesn't seem very defensive to me
nato has undermined its credibility in
that way and that's that's what gives
vladimir putin an opening i'm not saying
that vladimir putin is making totally
sincere honest you know innocent is a
lamb kind of arguments here he's not the
guy's a predator he does want to conquer
his neighbors
our leaders gave him an opening to do
that
and so that that creates a problem
that's the that's the problem of the
experts that's the problem of the rulers
that's the reason why we don't have a
whole lot of trust in them anymore i'm
michael knowles the michael knowles show
see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael noel show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.
on the matte wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show